[Music]
so I've been broke I've been broken I
know how it feels to be scared really
terrified I know how it feels to have so
many money fights with your spouse that
you both want to leave and I know what
it feels like to be wealthy because I am
know so I've walked a lot of the
different roads that you out there
listening to me or walking so the stuff
that I teach you is not stuff that is
theory from a textbook and there is zero
hypocrisy in it meaning everything I'm
telling you to do I have either done or
would do if I woke up in your shoes so
you hear me say that phrase a lot if I
woke up in your shoes because I want to
always be consistent to not ask you to
do or tell you to do or give you advice
to do something that I wouldn't do if I
were in your exact place in that
situation how would I handle that
situation
having coached millions of people in the
last 30 years on their money and having
become a millionaire by the time I was
26 losing it all by the time I was 28
rebounding as a debt-free
multimillionaire now decades later with
that set of experiences what would I do
if I could talk to the younger Dave if I
could talk to the Dave who didn't know
what the Dave now knows what would I
teach you to do and so I'm not sitting
in an ivory tower saying I'm worth tens
of millions of dollars and so your
little problems don't matter
you little problem to do matter they're
not little problems they're real
problems and I'm not sitting in an ivory
tower saying well I invest this way but
your little people should invest the
other way I don't do that I tell you
what I invest in and I do invest the way
I teach you to invest it's consistent
there's zero hypocrisy so you often hear
me say if I woke up in your shoes if I
were in your exact situation what what I
do and then I apply the principles that
I've allowed me and millions of others
to be successful with money to your
situation hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]